I mean the same thing
I don't want to try tricks this I'm just
being here you can't disconnect
running
[Music]
I I don't want you to fail but there's a
bigger picture and that if you're not
utilizing the technique that's a kind of
failure too so you have to watch the
ways that you're employing leverage or
external geometry to help you to either
make them weaker or you stronger in
addition to watching for muscle
isolation or muscle biting okay so one
way that always was interesting to me is
so when he pushes you'll see people will
hold and so I created a force loop right
pushes really you can disconnect so if
you want and so is he's pushed to me I'm
pushing into his arms you see that so
that's not really this do you see that
so same thing here when are you going to
grab you see you see what I did and now
now he can't he can't really push so I I
don't I don't care see he could be in
this weird this weird angle should not
right that would be love but I can still
hold this here okay so I don't you might
find that very hard but this is going to
be too easy so just keep on neutral you
see how we're 50/50 right it resists the
temptation to put him on the under
underside right
and you want to start feeling all of all
of this and not this
so as you feel that you had to let it go
and you have to put your mind so he he's
that he's got a more mechanical
advantage now do you see that because
he's straight and I'm now what you would
think would be your outer deltoids but I
don't care right is I'm just I'm working
on this go ahead I'm just working on
this part
if he feels me overriding he's gonna
help me let me come back to neutral you
see and if you can get there and some of
you can what I want you to start doing
is go if you can't get this I want you
to try to relax
well first I want you to not do that I
want you to try to relax
so beginner level you're going to not do
that you're going to keep the neutral
and he's going to help coach you next
level you're going to relax the biting
part okay the next level what I want you
to do is I want you to kind of feel how
things can move I know I don't want to
start doing this but you can consciously
kind of create waves waves in you it
might it might show up with the movement
but if you do I want you to stop to stop
as much as you can the movement but to
keep the internal movement going and
you'll you can use your mind to help you
imagine that okay and I know you're
getting tired but so why don't you go to
to Kiko okay and I'm going to move
everything
[Music]
okay here's what we're talking about so
we use this as a kind of like get the
four corners and wrong there and get off
but then you're you're too stiff so I
I'm good I'm moving go ahead and push
I'm moving
[Music]
okay so this is it this not it okay hey
I am good I am really able to do do you
understand too deep to kind of
deconstruct my beginner model of the
four corners and the iframe right on my
spine so I am but I don't want you to
start going back to not giving him a
pushing angle now you see that he keep
the advantage to him
okay another tool to help you understand
and so and we don't we don't want to
give him a mechanical disadvantage we
don't care if he gets a mechanical
advantage so I tried I'm trying to leave
this neutral and you should try to leave
it in neutral like he shouldn't because
he's trying to help me and I am go ahead
I am moving but you see how the arm is
not the arms now I'm not moving the arm
you see that so the arm is there and you
gotta do stuff I make it part of it you
can hear in my voice right
all right so go ahead so here here's my
here's my talking voice
abcdefg and he sees book ABC push really
hard DM g JJ LMNOP heart
[Music]
right try to get see if you can speak
because some of you are not breathing
and you're not aware of it and you're
not breathing because you you actually
have a tension in you right so okay we
always use exaggerated points to help
you so singing a goofy song or whatever
whatever you're just talk okay
okay
so we're gonna go to the we're going to
go to the inward spiral with all that in
mind okay so he's pushing and it's very
relaxed don't brace like that so I'm not
going like off and on everything is
still doing
[Music]
don't you start if you pay attention
instead of this all in here if he if
he's pushing really really really hard
and then I can get it get big reaction
out of here I have to
so you'll go push and don't change
anything you can't just turn your wrist
Hey your body your body is doing the
movement
[Music]
forever if you like you're pushing
so here we're using his so when what you
guys are thinking is that oh I'm gonna
get his balance to go like this you're
going to use a kind of anatomical
geometry that creates that do you see
that and this other stuff you're like
what is that okay well basically because
I made him push me he's going to he's
going to come forward from the move from
the movement of my arm right and then
he's going to hit he's going to hit
something with that does not yield as
he's moving forward so he goes like this
and that's what happens you see that
so that's entirely different from from
this happen you guys see that difference
okay so you know if you take the classic
form where I use his energy against and
well this is not using his energy
against him
so here we made a very gross energy
which witness push so he hits it and
then he goes do you guys see that so you
have to really resist the temptation to
do a kind of anatomical geometry that
has its place but not in this drill okay
and so if I if I stalemate him here and
then that's never going to happen so I
have to I have to let him in right and
that's why I said it's very much like
when he's pushing in the pushing drill
right boom we had that kind of led a man
boom and he hits he missed that thing I
suppose he goes oh like that or we go
like that there's a timing moon when he
hits that that's what I'm doing here
[Music]
so concentrate on the release on the
release that's that dancing drill right
concentrate on the release and then
you'll feel boom you'll feel where his
where his what you were trying to do
with that you're gonna get that exact
same thing because he comes here and
then that force goes that way and it
does what you were doing with his mass
you guys see that so he comes in boom
and I have it
[Music]
take tribe wit with when he when he
pulses boom when he hits that and you
have the the percussiveness and and the
associated swelling that's when it's
sweet you're being conditioned right
yeah
set up conditioning your arms and
shoulders
boom you're getting that conditioning
you just can't get on a on a barbell or
a novice machine or anything else like
that okay so the less the less you are
getting that form then you don't get
stronger okay
all right right